alright so there's an image going around
up Daniel Craig from the new Skyfall
movie as James Bond the very first
official image released now looking at
this image the first thing you might
notice is that Daniel Craig's bud has
seriously played a very large image in
selling some of his movies as of late
and he looked up some fan reactions and
well for the most part people like it
there are a few people who are like this
doesn't look like bond and all why have
they released this is the first
statement this is weird were you
expecting to be something like this the
reason casino royale is probably my
favorite Bond film is because it was so
different it took bond in a different
direction it wasn't like any of the
other films it was gritty it was dark it
was interesting and extremely
well-written and the action scenes were
fantastic it was a very well directed
film the fact that they chose that as
the first image to release I really like
because it seems like they're taking
bond in a different direction it's not
the same its original it's different
it's not just the same old you know look
at the camera and smile and wink it's
it's a different way of looking at bond
and the image screams bond I'm extremely
excited for Skyfall obstructed by Sam
Mendes and it's shot by Roger Deakins
who's my favorite cinematographer look
at this credentials he has shot some
incredible films so all in all I'm
really excited for Skyfall it's coming
out later this year it's when my most
anticipated films of the year let me
know what you think of the film well you
think at Casino Royale qantas also was a
disappointment for me but let me know
you think of the Bond franchise in
general I'd like to know what your
favorite Bond film is mine personally is
Casino Royale i know i know i know it's
new but whatever that's just how I am if
you liked this update you can subscribe
to my channel and get stuff mine eyes
Oh